uh let's talk about Indie ref actually
in a bit more detail should we the
former first minister of Scotland Henry
mcleish is with us now hello to you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning
um the minister wouldn't be drawn on
what he wanted to hear from the Supreme
Court today what about you
well I think he um you certainly did
have an exhausting number of questions
to answer but but look this is important
but I believe that we've reached a point
in the history of the evolution where
we've got to step back clearly the
Supreme Court is looking at the question
of could Scotland move forward have its
independence rate for everyone but I
would rather concentrate on whether
Scotland should actually have a
referendum I suspect that there's three
possible outcomes one is that Scotland
has the power to proceed with the
legislation secondly and it is reserved
to Westminster as per the Scotland act
1998 or thirdly the court may decide
that this is all very premature and they
will wait until the actual legislation
goes through this the Scottish
Parliament so that is one side of it
that's the legal side but I think the
politics of it is much more complex my
belief is that we shouldn't be having a
referendum now next year or even within
the next five years there are so many
important issues to be dealing with and
sadly the SNP have exhausted the
political energy in relation to
Independence that they're not applying
themselves to the kind of big issues
that are facing not only the United
Kingdom but to Scotland and my main
thesis is that we need to give
Devolution a chance to work that would
be looking at the Long View not the
short term and I think that the point
has to be made key that in 1707 we had a
manufactured Union in 1997 we started on
the Devolution Road this is 2022 and I
believe there's much more potential in
the Scottish Parliament to be realized
before we think of moving on you were
very much involved I think I'm right in
saying in Tony Blair's government in
order to set up uh Devolution or to
enable Devolution in the first place
um is Devolution working so far as you
would have hoped
no it's not key and I think that really
is the source of my concern I mean we
have 25 years now of the Scottish
Parliament he's done some remarkable
work but it's not realizing its
potential that's partly because since
since 19 since 2007 really we've had a
campaign for Independence but we've had
really no debate on where Scotland is
actually moving and if you look at the
current situation like the UK you're
experiencing multiple crises
Scottish public opinion is bitterly
divided there is no settled will of
course we have a situation where the um
momentum for Independence has has
disappeared and of course we have a
situation which worries me that Scotland
is stalled we're not applying ourselves
to the real issues that we're facing and
that's why I believe we come back to
devolution
we've had 25 years it seems a long time
but in the history of the UK Union it's
a short period I would like to think we
concentrate on some of the bigger issues
we concentrate on some of the policy
issues that I think are being neglected
and as far as I'm concerned the mood the
mind of Scots are not are not on this
question of having a referendum look
nobody has a crystal ball it may well be
the case in 20 25 years time maybe
earlier that Scots will decide they want
Divo Max we want home rule they want
more Devolution they want more
Independence
but my judgment is this is not the time
to be taking these big political and
constitutional decisions it's a time for
making Devolution work and for the
independence campaign to be sidelined so
that Scots can concentrate on the matter
on issues that matter to schools yeah
but that's a democracy for you Mr
mcleish isn't it you're not in power
anymore at the SMP very much is and they
want a referendum they say that's what
the Scottish people want
well I'm not sure that's the that
clearly comes from the the point you've
made key because look we have a
situation where the country's divided
down the middle 50 50 to be generous it
could be 60 40 in favor of staying in
the union look I think the union is
partly the Catalyst for all this unrest
if you look at the contempt the the look
at Ireland the contempt with which
they're looking at the Irish protocol
with Northern Ireland where was the
treat with contempt we have a situation
in England where there's restlessness
and some of the metropolitan areas and
of course under Johnson with this idea
of brittle unionism so part of my vision
is to see that Scotland concentrates now
on the issues that matter but
westminster's got to take a think to
itself it can't continue the way it's
going because it's centralized governing
of the United Kingdom it's perilous for
the four nations that make it up but I
think also okay we've got to realize
that when we talk about democracy
um very few Scots are actually in favor
of our second Independence referendum
known
we have a situation where the country is
divided and of course there's the famous
Abraham Lincoln comment that you know A
House Divided cannot stand so we've got
much to do in Scotland which has nothing
to do with Independence but what we have
got to do is to deal with some of these
important issues you're right I'm not in
power I'm not in politics but I do think
that after looking at the issue for 25
years being on the floor of the house
taking the legislation through
Devolution has got to work better the
parliament has huge potential and it's
important that not only the union
um sees itself not fit for a purpose but
the Scottish traditional part is
liberals labor conservatives actually
now apply more enthusiasm to the
Scottish Parliament and build a way
forward let's Nation build
let's institutional reform let's do a
number of things that will make Scotland
better that will give us a chance in the
long term to say okay is there a next
step for Scotland and at that point some
action may be taken but clearly this is
not the right time now to move forward
in the way that the SNP want to do it's
great to talk to you again thanks so
much for taking the time this morning
thank you thank you for the opportunity